>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THE SMOLLETT HATE CRIME POT
THICKENS.
THE STATE'S ATTORNEY KIM FOX IS
TAKING A LOT OF HEAT.
THEY ARE VERY ANGRY TODAY.
AND TRACE JOINS US WITH THE VERY
LATEST.
>> TALK ABOUT MOUNTING PRESSURE.
THE ASSOCIATIONS FOR EVERY
POLICE CHIEF IN EVERY CHICAGO
SUBURB HAVE GIVEN KIM FOX NO
CONFIDENCE AND DEMANDED HER
RESIGNATION.
POLICE ARE ALSO IRATE OF HER
REFUSING TO PROSECUTE LOW-LEVEL
FELONIES LIKE BURGLARY AND
SHOPLIFTING UNDER $1,000.
POLICE SAY THEFT IS NOW
PERMISSIBLE IN CHICAGO.
SHE SAID, I WAS ELECTED BY THE
PEOPLE OF COOK COUNTY TO PURSUE
COMMUNITY SAFETY, AND UPHOLD THE
VALUES OF EQUAL JUSTICE.
I PLAN TO DO SO THROUGH THE END
OF MY TERM, AND IF THE PEOPLE SO
WILL IT, INTO THE FUTURE.
AND CHICAGO'S NEWLY ELECTED
MAYOR SAYS SHE OWES THE PUBLIC
AN EXPLANATION BECAUSE THE
EVIDENCE AGAINST HIM WAS
COMPELLING.
THAT'S A BOLD STATEMENT BECAUSE
LIGHTFOOT WAS HERSELF A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
THEY GAVE SMOLLETT UNTIL TODAY